c'est la bonne nouvelle de la journée il
est arrivé il est juste là
ici je n'ai pas ouvert je voulais
vraiment le faire avec vous c'est
l'iphone et ce l'iphone et ceux de 2020
l'iphone est ce de la nouvelle version
je voulais présenter l'autre jour vous
avez extrêmement nombreux extrêmement
nombreuses à regarder cette vidéo donc
merci a vous déjà aujourd'hui on va
l'ouvrir on va le boxer c'est la
première prise en main je voulais
vraiment le temps avec vous parce que
cet iphone est ce est très particulier
il reprend le corps de l'iphone 8
l'ancien design d'apple ici j'ai
l'iphone on se promet que les designs
des iphones tendent à évoluer on a
toujours cette grande encoches là en
tout cas en 2019 en 2020 priori elle
devrait réduire un petit peu s'en empara
prochainement dont je vous invite dès
maintenant à vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas et je voulais vraiment
voir ce à quoi allait ressembler cet
iphone est ce une fois qu'on l'avait en
main même si je connais l'iphone 8
et bien c'est intéressant de pouvoir
voir se reproduit de 2000 voit ce que ça
donne et surtout comment je le ressens
une fois que j'ai dans les mains par
rapport à celui là dans quelques jours
il y aura le test dont je vous invite
déjà à vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
le cas mais avant toute chose et comme
je vous l'aï dit pendant toute la
période de confinement j'ai demandé de
m'en voyez vous vos vidéos savoir
comment ça passait chez vous et on va
donc se faire la vidéo du jour bonjour
monsieur greuze j'espère que ça se passe
bien cette période de confinement et
donc moi je suis en belgique je confiné
depuis cinq semaines ça se passe bien je
sais le baume du groupe de m'occuper
comme je peux chez moi et voilà quoi et
quand restez chez vous et continuer à
sauver des vies
ciao c'est un hobby et je laisse me
suivre sur ce merveilleux produits
merci à toi pour cette vidéo on va donc
passer tout de suite à l'ouverture et à
lunch boxing de l'iphone et ceux de 2020
voilà le carton toute première chose
ouvriers j'aime toujours les emballages
a toujours extrêmement pratique on peut
sortir très facilement on le voit
directement c'est drôle de retrouver ce
design la chapelle et surtout ce que
j'aime bien c'est l'expérience de boxing
est toujours extrêmement bien pensée
chez apple c'est un vrai et feuillages
et maintenant on s'ouvre à pas mal
j'aime bien moi j'ai pris la version
rouge
on le voit le petit côté red design by
apple et une california il a donc été
conçu par apple directement en
californie alors
n'ouvre on effectivement toute la notion
de productrice dans le produit trad sais
pas si vous connaissez
reste une association qui lutte contre
le vih et apple sort un modèle parents
modèles rouge en partenariat avec red
donc ça c'est plutôt bien et il ya une
partie qui est choisie c'est un euro je
sais plus exactement la somme qui
reversait la lutte contre le vih alors
on a quoi bienvenue sur l'iphone il nous
redonne un petit peu l'essentiel touch
edition reconnu effectivement ils
peuvent changer d'ici là par fayçal dit
ça je vous l'avais déjà dit le bouton
latéral on maintient enfoncé pour
allumer l'iphone et on appuie pour
mettre en veille ou le réactiver on l'a
dans plusieurs langues
de l'autre côté le bouton sandri
silencieux bon ça on connaît les boutons
de volume on nous donne quelques petites
astuces la recharge sans fil parce que
oui vous avez de la recharge sans fil ce
que vous n'aviez pas avant sur l'iphone
8 et sur l'ancien iphone et ce toujours
pour lightning pour venir recharger
bonbons voilà ça ça fonctionne on hâte
de courir le tiroir de cartes sim on va
voir tout ce qui va être garanti et bien
évidemment les pistes de colomb apple
qu'on retrouve toujours toujours dans le
même souci d'un boxing vous avez la
petite languette vous venez tirer et la
up
regardez ça c'est cool c'est drôle déjà
rien comme ça tout petit format
j'ai plus l'habitude d'avoir des petits
formats comme ça j'ai tout le temps des
gros smartphone ça c'est vraiment très
très très bizarre
une fois de plus si apple ça souffle
très facilement et c'est toujours très
très très bien pensé avant d'en garder
la tête de la boîte ont déjà regardé la
prise en main ça c'est maxi ou fin c'est
très bizarre je vous assure c'est très
bizarre d'avoir un tout petit smartphone
dans la main comme ça j'ai plus
réellement l'habitude j'avais l'habitude
avec les pixels pixels 4 notamment
devant des petits formats des écrans 5,8
pouces là on est sur du 4,7 pouces c'est
encore plus petits le logo qui est situé
au centre c'est plutôt bien on le voit
product red la petite caméra avec le
petit relief on retrouve vraiment le
design notamment de l'iphone 10r sur le
dos on retrouve l'iphone 8 de façade les
finitions connaît un nouveau fait par
apple c'est irréprochable ça marche
toujours très très très bien on va se
regarder ça dans quelques instants par
rapport à la taille par rapport au
format le restant dans la boîte
j'imagine somme toute assez classique
des petits écouteurs filaires qu'on va
pouvoir bien branché sur le port
lightning ici on parle de lightning
parce que ici il n'y a absolument plus
du tout deux prises jack pendant suite à
l'interview effectivement bien le bloc
de charger sipa de recharge rapide c'est
vraiment très très très standard son
câble lightning usb bons envoyés là
dessus rien de bien à gauche on reste
dans les basiques mais ça fonctionne
regardez là c'est extrêmement
intéressant
l'ag nouvel iphone est ce l'âge et le
pixel cadre de google qui est un des
plus petits formats qu'on puisse se
retrouver en ce moment c'est un écran 2
5,8 pouces et vous avez bien évidemment
à côté
l'iphone on se prend max qui est un des
plus grands smartphone en ce moment il
ya plein d'autres mais cela est quand
même extrêmement grand pull fabriqués
par apple je vais vous montrer la
différence et c'est vraiment là dessus
qu'on se rend compte que le nouvel
iphone est ce vraiment tout petit voilà
l'iphone est ce voilà un smartphone qui
aujourd'hui est un tout petit smartphone
c'est celui là c'est le pixel 4 et voyez
que le puil 7,4 et quand même plus grand
que ce qu'on va retrouver ici et voilà
un des smartphones et plus grand mais
néanmoins un smartphone d'apple c'est
l'iphone 11 pro mac ce qui lui est quand
même beaucoup plus grand et si vous
comparez les deux modèles d'apple on
voit que ça déborde de tous les côtés
par rapport à l'iphone os promax c'est
absolument incroyable la différence de
format que vous avez mais surtout ce qui
est dingue c'est que le pixel 4
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un tout petit
smartphone et si vous venez poser juste
par dessus l'iphone et ceux de deuxième
génération
il vient pas du tout recouvrir le pixel
4 on va bien le bord en eau le bord en
bas un peu sur le côté et c'est là on se
rend vraiment compte que ce smartphone
là est vraiment tout petit je fais
vraiment facilement tour avec maintenant
je vais recouvrir l'ongle de mon vagin
là je viens également le recouvrir mais
c'est un peu plus grand il est un peu
plus large donc pour toutes les
personnes qui aiment les formats
vraiment tout petit qui veut qu'elle
soit extrêmement compact l'iphone est ce
vraiment très pratique la même manière
on peut le glisser très très très très
facilement dans une poche de la
différence dans ce promax qui lui par
contre toujours à part tendance un petit
peu à dépasser ici pour l'allumer c'est
juste ici sur le côté c'est exactement
de la mauvaise que j'ai actuellement sur
mon iphone
on se prend max soit que c'est bizarre
de retrouver tochigi alors pourquoi pas
au final j'utilise très bien sur mon
macbook pro mais c'est vrai que sur un
iphone j'aurais jamais pensé retrouver
touch elle dit après c'est un truc qui
marche bien c'est étrange de se
retrouver aujourd'hui comme ça avec un
iphone touch il dit avec ce design lab
est quelque chose de très très très très
compact pourquoi pas faut vraiment
prendre ses repères ça c'est vraiment
pour l'essentiel je pense parce que moi
je suis habitué un très grand smartphone
j'utilise depuis quelques mois l'iphone
os pro mac c'est quand même très très
grand là les âmes sont en train de se
réinstaller donc il faut le temps que
les choses se fassent
laissez-moi quelques jours pour le
tester je vais vous en parlait et on
avis avec très très très surprenant fait
voir du côté de la caméra ça je vous
montrerai lormontaise pas minorer tout
de suite et ça c'est intéressant je suis
plutôt habitués à voir un taux de crédit
comme ça c'est très très très bizarre de
se retrouver également avec ce design là
aujourd'hui bon pourquoi pas faut le
temps de se refaire en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que même si le design date
un petit peu même si c'est pas le
dernier
design d'apple même si on n'est pas sur
des grands écrans bord à bord avec des
petites bulles des petites encoches des
caméras papou ce que vous voulez en tout
cas ici ce qu'on vient chercher c'est
pas ça ce smartphone s'adresse vraiment
à toutes les personnes qui veulent un
smartphone compact léger avec un format
qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui en 2020
mais par contre avec quelque chose
d'extrêmement actuelle en termes de
performances avec la puce à 13 bionique
qui marche vraiment bien je vous donnais
mon retour d'ici quelques jours pour
vous dire vraiment quelle expérience
j'ai avec ce smartphone en tout cas moi
je pense à plutôt intéressant si vous
n'aimez pas ce smartphone c'est que vous
êtes probablement pas dans la cible
c'est que vous ne recherchez pas un
smartphone avec un écran de 4,7 pouces
c'est que vous ne cherchez pas quelque
chose d'extrêmement fort si vous n'êtes
peut-être technophiles peut-être que
vous aimez mais plus grand écran
peut-être que vous voulez des grands
écrans pour le multimédia
pour moi c'est pas ce qu'on recherche et
là dessus ce qu'on a cherché là dessus
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
très très compact qui sera efficace mais
qui n'a pas vous apporter l'expérience
multimédia la plus dingue
puisque vous restez quand même sur des
formats d'écran qu'ils sont tout petits
mais c'est vraiment intéressant qu'apple
revienne là-dessus sur un petit format
4,7 pouces
je me verrais pas à moi d'utiliser un
écran 4,7 pouces mais sur un deuxième
smartphone ou un smartphone
professionnel
eh bien écoutez pourquoi pas et je le
dis et je le redis une fois de plus
parce que ça c'est extrêmement important
pour comprendre pourquoi est ce qu'apple
a fait ça comprend vraiment la stratégie
d'apple c'est que ce smartphone la
s'adresse vraiment parti qui cherche un
smartphone tout petit compact mais qui
ne va pas lésiner sur la puissance et
qui ne va pas lésiner sur je pense la
photo puisque avec une seule caméra
capteur de 12 mégapixels
je pense qu'apple vont quand même
vraiment sortir le grand jeu de ce
côté-là ça je vous lis dans quelques
jours vous invite donc dès maintenant à
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
pour marquer tout ce que vous voulez en
bas question interrogations suggestions
fort ce que je donne rendez vous très
très très très très très rapidement pour
vous donner mon résultat complet sur le
test de ce smartphone là d'ici là portez
vous bien non ils vous envoient beaucoup
d'amour hayato kaouki
[Musique]